un monsieur bonsoir après la chine les
etats unis la dea bientôt dans dix jours
l'urss
une journée complète de l'information
d'antenne 2 à marseille
je vous rassure tout de suite ce n'est
pas une rédaction parisienne qui vient
se pencher avec attendrissement ou avec
commisération sur les problèmes des
régions en france aucun d'entre vous
n'ont aucun autre nom des parisiens nous
avons tous nos racines provinciales et
nous y tenons beaucoup et je crois
qu'elles entrent pour beaucoup dans le
choix des différents sujets que nous
vous présentons chaque jour et si paris
prend souvent trop de place vous nous le
dites parfois dans nos journaux
et bien c'est que beaucoup de choses se
passent encore là bas et que
techniquement nos moyens sont évidemment
facilité par la proximité des lieux
d'événements mais ce soir nous sommes à
marseille comme nous le fûmes à 12h45
pour antenne de midi et à 18h30 pour
c'est la vie et nous rééditerons souvent
l'expérience dans d'autres régions de
france
la prochaine fois ce sera en bretagne
marseille je ne vous présente pas et je
ne m'engage pas dans la polémique sur la
deuxième ou troisième ville de france
propose plutôt de jouer cela dans 30
minutes tout juste sur la pelouse du
stade de gerland à lyon où les deux
équipes de marseille et de lyon les deux
footballs qu'il s'agisse ont précisément
opposés et on jouera la qualification en
première division et la descente en
seconde division je vous assure que tout
marseille ne parle que de cela ce soir
l'important pour marseille nous en
parlerons à l'aide d'un reportage tout à
l'heure et d'une manière générale toute
la seconde partie de ce journal sera
consacré aux marseille de 1980 mais tout
d'abord ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
dans le monde avec 7 ce bulletin de
santé du machin tito à un [ __ ] de
santé plutôt désastreuse je suis en vous
même la lésions du foie s'aggrave
l'hémorragie stomacale a repris et les
fonctions rénales ne se rétablissent pas
alors à tout moment bien sûr nous
pouvons intervenir pour donner des
suites à cette information assez
dramatique
deuxième coup de projecteur dans le
monde la dégradation des rapports
3 shing tonnes et teyran c'est
l'escaladé à nouveau hier soir en a fait
jimmy carter a annoncé de nouvelles
sanctions
et il a commencé à faire allusion à une
priorité
les sanctions les menaces nous font peur
nous n'avons pas peur de ces menaces et
de ce sanctions ça veut dire ici ou jeu
quand il décide de faire de la guerre à
genoux tout le peuple n'est ce pas est
prête à faire à se défendre
n'est ce pas la langue dépendance et la
liberté d'autres pays et déjà vous savez
que notre émission comment s'est déroulé
ce pas et que tout le monde que tu grand
militaire at et religieux toutes les
couches sociales se sont soulevés contre
leixia et l'impérialisme américain
penser la même chose alors toujours à
l'étranger le raid israélien de cette
nuit au sud liban 12 morts 10 les
phalangistes libanais simorre disent les
israéliens état d' alerte dans tout le
sud liban et il ya une heure nous
apprenions que deux observateurs de
l'onu avaient été enlevés par des
ministre conservatrice de casques bleus
seraient morts pendant swing tunisie le
mouvement des commandos de gafsa pour s
en prendre aux touristes français en
tunisie c'est ce que viennent déclaré
l'un de ses membres tout à l'heure vives
réactions en france après l'exécution de
presse des condamnés notamment des
partie gauche de la cgt et de la cfdt
et puis au lendemain de la diffusion du
premier reportage de bernard rapp sur
l'état d'esprit dé cuba aujourd'hui
voici aujourd'hui les toutes premières
images que nous ayons jamais tourné à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade du pérou
l'ambassade qui s'est dégarni
aujourd'hui encore sensiblement puisque
50 réfugiés viennent encore d'arriver en
espagne
serge me serais 2000 mètres carrés pour
dix mille personnes il en reste
aujourd'hui environ 3000 sur le
périmètre de l'ambassade du pérou à cuba
trois mille personnes qui subsistent
dans des conditions d'hygiène certes
améliorée mais dont la condition reste
celle d'hommes et de femmes qui fuient
avec leurs familles
il y à la minorité de ceux qui refusent
de régime
et puis les autres le plus grand nombre
qui fuient des conditions de vie souvent
ingrate un camp de réfugiés un passeport
un visa
c'est tout ce qu'ils demandent demain à
cuba une grande manifestation de masse
est prévue pour dénoncer ceux qui
partent mais aussi et probablement pour
ressouder l'unité nationale oui ces
images ne sont pas d'une très grande
qualité technique nous en accusons mais
ce sont je vous rappelle les toutes
premières images que nous avons reçus de
l'intérieur de l'ambassade péruvienne un
de l'homme qui avait tenté de poignarder
madame gandhi a été poignardé
aujourd'hui du même il était dans sa
chambre d'hôpital et c'est là des
malades de l'établissement qui s'en est
pris à lui enfin zuma ouais vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui on ne doit plus dire
c'est la rhodésie mezine bah ouais et
plus encore depuis aujourd'hui puisque
c'est cette nuit précisément ont eu lieu
les cérémonies d'indépendance dans
l'enthousiasmé général mais non sans
quelques manifestations de violence deux
morts et plusieurs blessés chaque câble
antilles des incidents ont tant donné
une journée qui aurait dû être après
huit ans d'une dure lutte armée
réservé à la joie populaire en effet
deux personnes ont été tuées et 30
autres blessées par des attentats à la
grenade dont les auteurs n'ont pas été
identifiés
la statue de l'homme qui fonda le pays
il ya près d'un siècle cecil rhodes et
différents bâtiments publics ont
également été lapidée il n'en demeure
pas moins que l'émergence aux frontières
de l'apartheid
également multiraciale dirigé par le
chef d'un mouvement de libération comme
mugabe devant un événement unique pour
un continent l'afrique
les problèmes ne manqueront voilà en
tout cas ce qu'ont voulu marquer en
participant aujourd'hui à la fête aux
côtés du prince charles d'angleterre
un grand nombre de leaders politiques
africains affaires françaises maintenant
la sphère de breuil tout d'abord le rpr
n'est pas favorable à la convocation de
la haute cour pour michel priés de ski
c'est ce qu'a dit le député jean falala
quant à gaston defferre qui étaient ici
même cet invité à 12h45
il l'a fait savoir que pour lui la haute
cour dans cette affaire était le
meilleur moyen de faire savoir
précisément toute la lumière sur cette
affaire
corse une réunion à l'elysée mardi
prochain autour du chef de l'état et de
six parlementaires de l'île ainsi que
des maires d'ajaccio et de bastia ce
matin alexandre sanguinetti était
l'invité de valéry giscard d'estaing
bretagne marée noire le parlement
européen de strasbourg votent un crédit
de près de 3 millions de francs pour les
comptines istres et et puis martinique
début de la grève générale
non limitée la guadeloupe n'a pas suivi
et les syndicats martiniquais sont
quelque peu déçu économie berliet c'est
fini ça vienne c'est fini en tout cas
vous ne verrez plus ces deux cibles sur
les camions français tous s'appelleront
désormais renault et tous porteront le
fameux losange dessiné par face à rennes
les gens payent eux à côté du sigle
maison le losange signé vasarely il n'y
aura plus désormais qu'une seule marque
renault
surtout les camions produit jusqu'ici
par saviem et berliet les deux branches
de la filiale poids lourds de la firme
national
la marque unique au printemps 80 c'est
le symbole de l'intégration dans une
gamme normalisé des divers modèles qui
avait quelquefois une double utilité
la restructuration des usines aura
toutefois entraîner la suppression de
5000 emplois en deux ans retraite
anticipée départs volontaires et
mutations la marque unique c'est aussi
la fin d'une période transitoire qui
aura permis d'unifier le réseau
commercial pour faire face à la
concurrence qui avait réduit par exemple
la part de renault en france de 50 à 40
pouces cette marque a permis aussi de
déclencher la contre-offensive à
l'exportation notamment vers l'europe et
les états unis
c'est un grand espoir que l'exportation
pour renault véhicules industriels parce
que le marché français ne représente
tout compte fait que 2% du marché
mondial alors que le marché nord
américain représente 34% ce marché et
c'est grâce aux efforts développés par
l'entreprise à l'exportation que nous
avons envoyé au delà des mers et au delà
nos frontières 41 % de notre production
c'est comme ça que nous avons fait
flotter l'emploi chez renault véhicules
industriels
si nous voulons réduire si nous avons
voulu réduire notre effectif c'est parce
que la productivité va nous donner plus
de camions et cette productivité est
nécessaire pour maintenir nos coûts sur
les marchés étrangers
grâce à ses nouveaux modèles comme ce
quart turbo de 360 chevaux renault aura
augmenté cette année sa production de
6000 poids lourds il a repris du terrain
à ses concurrents en allemagne grande
bretagne et italie et pénétrer les états
unis grâce à son alliance avec la firme
américaine mac
les chiffres du commerce extérieur pour
le mois de mars encore un déficit 5
milliards 8 ce qui fait près de 15
milliards pour le seul premier trimestre
évidemment les l'augmentation du brut
ils sont beaucoup dans ce déséquilibre
paris grève du nettoiement extension
maintenant au réseau de la sncf toutes
les négociations ont échoué dans le
métro parisien quant au métro
marseillais tout va bien c'est un petit
peu cher mais tout va bien
et puis cette critique de la cfdt à
l'égard de la journée cégétiste de jeudi
prochain
c'est une manifestation anti unitaire a
dit la cfdt
les obsèques de jean paul start je vous
rappelle que
cortège doit partir de l'hôpital
broussais dans le 14e arrondissement de
paris à 14 heures pour se rendre à pied
à au cimetière montparnasse et une
cérémonie qui devrait être très
impressionnante bien que tout acte
officiel soit bannie aucun discours
aucune prise de parole vous rappelle que
sartre est le thème central da postroff
qui se déroulera tout à l'heure à 21h30
alexis lamant raymond aron et puis tout
de suite après apostrophe vous pourrez
voir l'adaptation de michel mitrani de
la chambre justice le procès du médecin
fou fou et le terme puisque le docteur
peignot qui est poursuivie aujourd'hui à
paris et maintenant interné à vie il y a
neuf ans 71
il avait littéralement saigner à blanc
un jeune malade lui-même sortait
d'hôpitaux psychiatriques et ce sont les
médecins qui n'ont pas empêché qu'il
puisse exercer sa profession qui était
aujourd'hui poursuivi compte rendu
paul le faire en feuilletant ce dossier
on y trouve cinq visages d'abord celui
de l'enfant didier c'est en bonne petite
brune blonde
il est mort saigner à blanc sous le
scalpel et sur la table de la cuisine il
second visage pierre pillot le médecin
fou le bon docteur qui peu à peu en
plusieurs étapes en plusieurs années a
sombré a basculé dans le délire total et
qu'il exprimait plus sa folie qu'au
travers de son art de soigner qui était
devenu l'art de tuer troisième visage de
docteur troncin président du conseil de
l'ordre départemental des médecins de
seine-saint-denis silhouette de médecins
notable peut-être fatigués 12 médecins
de famille l'indifférence l'ignorance et
les imbécilités administrative ne l'ont
pas prévenu d'une grande plus danger
public que représentait le médecin
peut-être aurait-il pu enfin reste deux
visages le professeur denis caire plus
l'usagé massif chauffe et le professeur
colonna plus jeunes + mas et cheveux
poivre et sel ou deux des savants
débordés
on laissait peignot en liberté tous deux
n'ont pas osé lui interdire la médecine
depuis toujours il soigne chaque jour
peut-être ils guérissent
aujourd'hui tout le monde sait qu'ils se
sont trompés qu'ils peuvent se tromper
tout le monde le sait que les premiers
vous me direz ça coûtait un enfant voilà
pour tout ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
hors de marseille ici en ce moment on
parle toujours de l'horrible drame sud
de la cité la cravache 9 mort avant-hier
on parle de la reprise du travail au
début de la semaine
au début de cette semaine aux ateliers
de réparation navale terrain après 18
mois d'interruption parle du problème du
chômage 40 mille demandeurs d'emploi
pour la seule agglomération marseillaise
on parle aussi des bons résultats du
port autonome qui démarre derrière moi
qui a fait en effet plus de 15 % de
mieux en tonnage plus de 15% que l'année
dernière on parle aussi des problèmes de
la coopérative de montbrillant et c'est
un répit on parle aussi de ce que disent
les parisiens et les autres sur
marseille et là il ya une expression a
surtout pas employer c'est celle de
chicago sur mer c'est vrai depuis le
début disons depuis la fin de la guerre
marseille détenait le record de la
criminalité il y avait une tradition
historique à sa carbone mémé guérini la
french connection c'est une ville
portuaire c'est une ville de transit
seulement depuis deux ans les choses ont
radicalement changé
la répression est impitoyable et la
criminalité évolué le reportage de
denise blais
oh
marre du téléphone en 1978 un règlement
de compte onze morts
le bar chic de marseille le syntras
tombe pour proxénétisme
le bar l'aiglon un règlement de compte
par plasticage pas de morts
découverte de courses truquées à
l'hippodrome beau rallye de marseille
janvier 80 le sporting barre ferme pour
trafic et exploitation de machines à
sous drogue plus d'une tonne de cannabis
30 kg d'héroïne saisis 330 trafiquants
arrêtés
le milieu marseillais donc bien malade
en effet depuis le début de l'année 1979
mille personnes ont été arrêtées pour
grande criminalité
en comptant faux monnayeurs kidnappers
est proxénète la délinquance est de plus
en plus jeunes ceci naturellement nous
pose un problème un problème de police
auparavant il existait vous le savez un
milieu maintenant il n'existe plus
seulement amelio tout au moins il existe
je dirais beaucoup plus souterrain mais
par contre il existe des milieux des
petits milieux qui se font et se défont
au gré des affaires nous avons souvent
des jeunes qui nous commettent des voix
la mare mais après avoir simplement faut
voler une voiture au même commis un
petit cambriolage
ce sont des jeunes bien souvent
inexpérimentés qui n'hésitent pas à
tirer et être les auteurs de drames
nous avons un mort sec 81 10 mille
étrangers recensés dont une cinquantaine
de milles de nord africains
ceci pose le problème de leur accueil
pour beaucoup qui n'ont pas de travail
il leur faut naturellement trouver de
quoi vivre et je suis obligé de
constater que parmi et les auteurs
notamment d'agression sur la voie
publique nous entrons à bon nombre ceci
ne doit pas d'ailleurs ternir l'image de
marque de tous ceux qui travaillent
pour lutter contre une délinquance de
plus en plus jeunes la police
marseillaise c'est depuis quelques mois
réorganisés restructurer en plus des
îlotiers des gardiens en tenue qui kadri
tous les jours quartier par quartier 90
hommes en sixième jour et nuit
patrouille dans la ville
ces policiers recherchent le flagrant
délit interpelle et parfois une
arrestation sur la voie publique peut
être le début d'une grosse affaire
criminelle ou encore de terrorisme sont
partis à pied la ville
ils prennent aussi beaucoup de risques
avec des véhicules dont on peut dire
qu'ils sont moins compétitifs que ceux
des truands
les audois marseille ne détient plus
aujourd'hui le record du banditisme se
sont paris et la ville de nice qui sont
en tête des villes préoccupant voilà
cette image de marseille ville
criminelle un avocat marseillais
l'avocat dit si paul lombard souhaite un
petit peu la voir disparaître ils
demandent dans un livre dont nous rend
des comptes hier ya soir paul faire
plaidoyer pour marseille il demande
l'acquittement de sa ville et cette
ville peut être rebelle veut les voir
sur ces images que réalise en ce moment
jacques cristobal pratiquement au terme
d'un réquisitoire du procureur en quatre
parties marseille ville de galéjades
marseille ville polluantes et vous voyez
que sur ces images elle peut ne pas
l'être ville indocile et métropole de
déséquilibrer ce déséquilibre on avait
cru pouvoir le régler un moment par la
création de fos-sur-mer et bien j'ai
relu les journaux d'il ya dix ans
celle aventures du siècle pour la france
y est on est le poumon de l'an 2000 pour
marseille et bien aujourd'hui jean
claude renault a pu constater un certain
désenchantement pour ne pas dire plus
après les espoirs du début des années 70
1970 il y a dix ans les moutons de la
crau doivent s'éclipser devant le
complexe de fos-sur-mer le grand delta
du rhône concurrents sera celui du nord
avec un port gigantesque une zone
industrielle de onze mille hectares pour
annoncer ce séisme régionales les
journaux ne trouve plus de qualificatif
on promet 300 mille emplois en quinze
ans pour les pouvoirs publics
l'optimisme est de rigueur la première
question c'était il ya deux ans qu'on se
la pose est est-ce que nos enfants
auront du travail
mais aujourd'hui il semble que les
enfants de la région en or en plus
qu'ils ne peuvent en faire aujourd'hui
les bouches du rhône compte 10% de
chômeurs
plus que la moyenne nationale sur le
plan industriel le bilan de fossés vite
dressé environ 11000 emplois dont 9000
pour les deux grands sidérurgistes
sol-mer et ugi nation le reste se
répartit notamment entre la pétrochimie
les raffineries et des fds et les
constructions métalliques
le bilan est décevant car les industries
lourdes n'ont pas donné naissance à de
plus petites en aval qui aurait apporté
des emplois induits exemple la soul mais
elle exporte sa production près de 4
millions de tonnes en particulier vers
v3 est les automobiles américaines mais
ici dans la région
rares sont les utilisateurs de ces
assises est ce là encore en reste à un
stade artisanal
la paroisse et à surgir là j'avoue j'ai
pas un seul point en deux parties il a
une grosse partie de lapin en italie
pour bien c'est là que les meilleurs
marchés
les italiens sont enrichis
c'est pas trop de bonne qualité ça ne
c'est moins cher
finalement vers l'intérieur vers le
grand delta industriel fos sur mer est
un escalier qui débouche sur pas grand
chose par contre vers le grand large
faus a développé et développera encore
l'importance du port autonome de
marseille deuxième port d'europe
derrière rotterdam marseille c'est
surtout le pétrole malgré un sérieux
ralentissement de 74 à 78
il ya aujourd'hui plus de 80% de
produits pétroliers sur un trafic de 110
millions de tonnes depuis fausse le brut
par vers lyon la suisse et l'allemagne
en empruntant le pipeline sud européen
pour le reste c'est à dire le vrac et
les marchandises diverses
le port autonome s'efforce de rattraper
son retard dans le domaine des navires
porte conteneurs
là encore fausse a permis la
construction d'un terminal de près d'un
kilomètre de long les atouts
particuliers du port de marseille est
bien entendu c'est d'abord d'avoir
justement c'est ses installations de fos
fossé le port de marseille fos et un
port sans limite en plus de ça les
armateurs ont intérêt à ce que leur
navire parcours des courtes distances
or il est évident que marseille est
particulièrement bien placé pour les au
delà de ce us par rapport au port du
nord puisqu'il ya des économies de
navigation de six jours d'autre part
d'autre part nous avons quand même un
développement du trafic avait les ports
arabe
et là encore on peut dire que le port de
marseille particulièrement bien placé
pour desservir le proche et moyen-orient
marseille a donc des réserves de
capacités mais aussi de matière grise en
réalisant les équipements de fos sur mer
les ingénieurs du port on taquine
technologies de pointe et aujourd'hui
ils l'exportent à travers le monde
entier
voilà je vous disais tout à l'heure que
deux observateurs de l'onu un français
admet qu'un venait d'être enlevée et
bien puis en rien de femme apprend à
l'instant qu'il vient d'être libéré au
sud liban
alors marseille a aujourd'hui d'autres
atouts par exemple les industries de la
mer aujourd'hui quelque 150 entreprises
travaillent autour du numéro un mondial
de ce qu'on appelle l'ingénierie sous
marines et la comex bien entendu mais il
ya aussi les points noirs et le point
noir de cette année est particulièrement
de ce soir c'est le football l'olympique
de marseille qui est une équipe
prestigieuse par le passé ne va pas bien
du tout elle est depuis le début du
championnat dans les profondeurs du
classement 19e
aujourd'hui et va se battre ce soir à
lyon pour garder sa place en première
division lyon qui n'est pas très bien
classé non plus 18e le reportage
d'olivier rey l'olympique de marseille
est encore en crise une de plus l'om
accuse aujourd'hui un déficit de 1
million 200 mille francs
un passif qui est le résultat de
plusieurs mauvaise gestion l'om a donc
besoin d'argent
heureusement les nouveaux dirigeants ne
sont pas venus les mains vides
nous avons donc injecté nasreen faim
depuis que les humains au coeur et
aujourd'hui encore ce qui précède la
ville aux femmes en faire appel
nous ce qu'on veut c'est quelqu'un qui
l'a transformé en ligue 1 comme continue
à gagner des matches et le rêve des
supporters il y a le folklore mais aussi
la réalité et les dirigeants ont
remporté une victoire importante grâce
au tribunal de commerce
vous savez que la procédure de fusion
sur proviseur de perte de poursuites
permet à l'entreprise qui est qui en
bénéficient d'avoir ses dettes gelé
pendant une période 2 3
pendant cette période un curateur est
désigné et elle doit fournir est
présenté au tribunal après cette ce
délai de trois mois un plan de
redressement pour obtenir ce jugement
les dirigeants avaient préparé un solide
dossier pour que l'om soit reconnue
comme une société commerciale d'intérêt
régional l'oncle du mans c'est et toutes
les petites entreprises par le membre du
salarié je crois que l'intérêt commun
régional se déduit une façon indirecte
lorsque l'olympique de marseille gagne
un match ou même lorsqu'elles existent
cela des conséquences au niveau des
transports en commun cela a des
conséquences au niveau de la
restauration
cela a des conséquences au niveau du
tirage de la presse cela a des
conséquences indirectes très importante
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la
municipalité quand vous irez voir
monsieur gaston defferre
la subvention de la balle est maintenant
dans le camp des joueurs des joueurs qui
sont en partie responsables de la
situation actuelle payer cher ils n'en
n'ont pas donné pour leur argent et ils
le savent c'est d'abord les jouant c'est
quand même pas les dirigeantes les jours
sur le terrain c'est nous et je
conquêtes depuis le début de cette
saison on ne peut pas dire qu'on a
vraiment formés
une équipe pour jouer les le rôle qui
nous était attribué un début de saison
4e titre de champion
neuf victoires en coupe l'om est le club
le plus titré de france
mais ce club est actuellement sur six
est bien tout à l'heure précisément
d'antenne 2010 le député maire de la
ville gaston defferre disette à patrick
lecocq son intention de tout faire pour
aider l'om à s'en sortir nous l'écoutons
marché j'espère gagner ce soir et si
l'om gagne la municipalité est prête à
faire un effort tout chauds tels que
religion ou continuer dé l'om et que nos
deux clubs trois deviennent bientôt
premier et gagne de nouveau la coupe de
france mais aussi sur la subvention
municipale est élevé mais combien
meilleur ennemi autorisation de payer ce
n'est pas une obligation
elle ne sera payé que si nous estimons
que nous devons le faire et que l'enjeu
est important il faut absolument que
marseille gagne ce soir au stade gerland
c'est à dire à lyon tous les résultats
du championnat dans le journal de
pierre-alain c'est à dire vers 22h50
alors s'il football boîte un petit peu à
marseille la culture elle se porte
plutôt bien
vous pose de suivre georges bigot et
jacques manga vert dans le spis de la
geisha ripper qui est situé dans le
quartier du panier dans le quartier le
plus ancien de marseille là où fut fondé
massalia une charte culturelle a été
signé il y a cinq ans entre la ville et
l'état alors où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui est bien sous la pluie mais
ce petit hier leur bébé 150e rang que on
décide à marseille de construire un
hospice pour enfermer les mendiants qui
a fait ça toute la ville et les plans de
cet hospice sont confiés à un architecte
extraordinaire pierre puget
marseillais qui a construit ici
probablement l'oeuvre la plus importante
depuis
non
l'eau
une charité a donc l'histoire très
longue elle ad'abord abriter une
population sur fais misérables et puis
on la révolution française
plus de subsides la vieille charité a
servi à recueillir des vieillards et des
enfants
et puis ce à partir de 1830 que l'on en
a fait une caserne qui abritait un
régiment d'infanterie coloniale et à
partir de 1922 lorsque l'on a commencé à
détruire dans marseille
les vieux quartiers dits de derrière la
boue les murs de la vieille charité ont
abrité les familles dans le besoin qui
habitait ce vieux quartier et qui en ont
été expulsés alors aujourd'hui on la
respecte et je crois qu'on a rouvert une
carrière pour ça en effet on a donc ré
ouvert les carrières de la couronne la
couronne c'est un petit village après
l'estac en direction de martigues ou des
carnets ont été exploités de tout temps
pour construire à marseille notamment la
mairie nul fort saint-jean les forces et
nicolas les pierres de la couronne cette
rose excuses
et maintenant qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir je me sens tellement énorme
qu'il existe beaucoup de projets en
particulier l'ina l'institut national de
l'audiovisuel s'installerait dans c'est
mieux probablement aussi un département
de la bibliothèque nationale
et puis une partie des galeries
pourraient être utilisés pour les
artisans déjà l'avé charité a commencé à
retrouver vie puisque deux galeries ont
été rénovés et on y organise
régulièrement des expositions en ce
moment par exemple il y à une exposition
consacrée aux lithographe marseillais
jour berthod et puis une autre
exposition très intéressant qui a été
monté par des enfants les enfants de
différents établissements scolaires de
la ville et l'exposition s'appelle le
rucher le musée l'enfant
comme vous le voyez il pleuvait toute la
semaine dernière et toute la semaine à
marseille mais aujourd'hui le temps
était magnifique pour l'instant et il
est en train de décliner mais c'est tout
naturel le soleil ne se couche et il y à
exactement une demi-heure au tout début
de ce journal d'une manière générale il
faut dire que pour la météo il a fait
doux dans le midi au nord de la seine le
temps fut plus frais avec quelques
pluies mais les températures ont partout
et est agréable heures pour demain
j'imagine ça vous intéresse et bien le
temps sera nuageux et frais avec de
petites pluies qu'ils ont sur toute la
région nord de la manche aux alpes tout
tout de suite cette ligne en dessous des
éclaircies alterneront avec des passages
nuageux on me dit qu'ils les vents
souffleront très fort sur la mer du nord
et que le mistral s'installera cette
nuit alors que pas un poil devant pour
l'instant ce sera cette nuit à marseille
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
22h50 je voulais dire alain demain
samedi ennemis à 12h30 consacré un sujet
qui vous passionne la vivisection avec
jean claude mongeau et puis demain à 20
heures de paris cette fois
léon zitrone voilà vous avez toutes les
amitiés de marseille et de sa région je
vous souhaite une très bonne fin de
semaine à lundi
à